[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a fan made game
called markiplier adventures 2. now this
is a sequel to markiplier adventures
1 which was made by jeff kyler14
about two or three years ago now he's
done a lot of cool things he's even made
an animation for me
and this game has been in the works for
so long
he's told me about all the struggles
that he's had to try to finish it just
with personal stuff in his life
but it finally came out and it came out
a couple of months ago and i wanted to
play it
boy do i feel better is this supposed to
be me
is that me boy do i feel better hello i
guess that game took a lot out of me
who's doing an impression of me who who
is that that's not me i guess that game
took a lot out of me
oh later that morning i'm coming
oh that's a weird thing to shout okay
hello weird it doesn't have any
[Music]
ah that's hilarious
and why does this plot seem cliche i
don't know
i didn't make it oh boy what the hell
the hell oh
oh no time
tim are you okay
oh never let anyone or anything hurt you
my little biscuit oh
thank you mom oh i guess we have to
follow this path
yeah the weird path that was drawn okay
we're gonna go on an adventure oh yeah
so this game came out
or uh the first part of this game came
out a while ago and it's just really
cool oh my god
we're in a comic book click to throw
wharf stashes
the scribbles won't hurt you then why
did i blow it up
i just blew it the [ __ ] up poof
they won't hurt me oh they won't hurt me
why would i kill them all
poof deadly poof balls oh jeez
oh my god that's like the original
dubstep music that i
i used so long ago i remember that stuff
i the first time i ever made an outro i
used this music
just because it was part of the the fall
of slenderman i didn't make an
outro until the fall of ah
sorry ah [ __ ] i gotta go all the way
back well
i am an idiot and i do fail a lot at
everything that i tried to do
so it's to be expected that i suck ass
and die
all right but anyway yeah so
that was way back in the fall slenderman
that this particular brand of music is
being played
[ __ ] god damn it i'm such a bag of
dick
yeah oh yeah i don't know why why am i
still killing all the scribbles
they literally won't hurt me they're
just peaceful things in this world
and i'm blowing up everything because
i'm a dick
okay we got this huh yeah there we go
oh boy oh boy oh [ __ ] man this is a lot
harder than i thought it'd be
yay i made it where am i now
the way out is it now fake me
yeah whoa i know right whoa
believe how amazing this place is what
is this with the sun
what's this green stuff on the ground oh
my god is that
dirt i know right oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] let's go
okay i don't know what challenge we're
facing but i know that you got my back
and that's what's important tim
here we go i guess wherever the hell we
are i don't know how i got here or why
i'm here
but i'm good okay
[Music]
what i don't know what big toe of what
penis monster i saw over there but what
the hell was that i just saw a leg and
it wasn't a
it wasn't [ __ ] god damn it i'm such
dick-a-tree all right guys enough
enough sucking ass time to get to work
here eh
[ __ ] i'm bad how can i be this bad at
platformers no one right
no i'm a terrible gamer no i'm a
disgrace
to all gamers around the world whoa it
was a penis monster
it was it's
those are some big hmms oh my god
the disgusting flesh monsters that are
from the spore series oh boy this looks
bad
oh that's the five nights at freddy's
music right there
oh this is so cool going through like
all these different games
oh it's so cool what's in the distance
over there is this supposed to be
slenderman or something else
because it's been a while since i played
a slenderman game
it's been a while since there's been a
slenderman game made god that craze died
down
and it's weird to think that the uh the
five nights at freddy's craze is lasting
longer than the slenderman craze did
because that was that was ridiculous
when that first happened
i mean it was first the amnesia craze
and then slenderman came about and then
a slew of other indoor games and then
there was a bit of a drip
a drip a drop you gotta be kidding me
what what do you see
do we really have to go away
i'm afraid so oh i know and i think in
the original markiplier adventures there
definitely was slenderman
oh hello oh hello i do appreciate all
the art too that's something that
uh jeff kyler definitely worked on or
his name is actually john i think
uh but just something that he's worked
on so hard and i appreciate all the
labor of love
that's been put into this game and i
just it's dripping with
like history and it's dripping with
these cool references and it's dripping
with all sorts of stuff
[Music]
is that worf stash are you all rimer
you look pretty down
[Music]
oh man i i i should volunteer to do the
voice acting for this because
i want to make sure that it's good i'm
not saying it's bad whoa hang on back up
i'm not saying it's bad
i'm not i'm not saying it's bad but i'm
right here
and i could do it so i could do it i
i wanna i wanna contact uh him so uh
that i can actually do the voice acting
for this because it's really cool but
i'm gonna allow him
or whoever's doing the voice acting to
carry on because
this is their baby their labor of love
and it's really cool whoa whoa whoa wait
a minute wait a minute
i thought you were dead yeah he's been
dead a lot
i got revived myself
i got revived by some too
oh by some dude was it purple guy
oh thanks wharf stash thanks for
disappearing in a poof cloud of pink
what the frick uh i say [ __ ]
thank you whoa tim got big are you okay
what the hell oh oh okay
oh boy oh boy oh boy
i don't think i'm gonna survive this one
so were you just playing with all the
big box berries
were they finally nice to you for once
and they're live
hello poof that's right poof
poof yeah that's right you don't want to
mess with me
i don't want to mess with me no one
wants what happens whoa
i can see it [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay then holy [ __ ]
are all of them just freddy hello freddy
okay goodbye freddy
all right i see how this is
poof
that's gonna get annoying real quick
well not to me i never get tired of poof
[ __ ] there was no one there that was
a lie i should just keep up the spam
i'm gonna kill all you bastards
okay all right then man this is really
cool i like this a lot
i mean it's actually kind of amazing
what he's managed to do what he's
managed to do with
just a platformer because platformers
are like the ubiquitous
gaming there was nothing there god
dammit i am just going to keep spamming
if you're going to be like that
platformers are some of the most simple
games to make but it's just
the character around the platformer and
it's like
what you do with the art and the
environment and what it means in the
story like that's what really makes
like a platformer actually come together
and i really do appreciate all that's
been done here
and it's just it's just charming and
delightful
it's charming and delightful
oh there was one hidden there okay so
there are ones in the darkness
but they will not stop me oh no oh
anybody there huh this is if i was
actually in
uh in a five nights at freddy's
restaurant and i had some sort of a
weapon with me
you better believe your ass that i'd be
spamming it everywhere i go
especially one that would just shoot
wharf stashes non-stop
whoa hey whoa
oh yay i knew i'd find you here who the
hell a nurse
nurse nurse nurse
what are you doing here i should ask you
the same thing ah man get a get a better
fitting
shirt what are you doing here there are
kids watching what's going on here
nurse i think i got a bad feeling about
this
uh oh is it not nurse oh who's your
little friend
don't be afraid of nurse she's probably
not a monstrosity
that's tiny box tim he's my little
bisque he's my little biscuit he's so
adorable
something's bad is gonna happen what
i didn't say anything i i said something
right i just love that her shirt
it's just two buttons barely contained
by her boobs first off you were in the
game i played and now
you're in this comic book ah what
happened
yeah what happened well mark it's a long
story
but i guess i might as well tell it all
right sure i won't tell you to shut up
this time the last time we met you got
stabbed in your butt
insane jeff barged in and nearly killed
us
when you told me to escape i went
through a vent that led to the outside
of the hospital
oh okay as soon as i made it out a
vortex appeared out of nowhere
and the next thing i know of i was home
yay
anyways this morning i was getting ready
to go to work but as soon as i opened my
front door
i saw this comic book on my doorstep and
i decided to look into it
seemed like forever ago now but i also
fought off a
ton of hordes of demons and here i am
oh okay no keep talking i'm very
interesting in this story what did you
just say to me
sorry it's an interior reflex i've got a
tumor in my amygdala it just makes me
say that
i can't calm nurse you know what's
[Music]
so you're telling me that you're a real
person and a real nurse
oh okay but aren't you worried about
getting fired from absences
no i was treated like dirt anyways oh
man i was a bit of a now i feel bad now
that you're personified and not an
actual
you know not just a figment of my
imagination you know the whole concept
of the nurse was that i was a doctor
operating alone and then
the nurse was an alternate personality
of mine that was just like
there wasn't there was here's the big
secret for all of you that have watched
my surgeon simulators in my mind
in those instances the nurse didn't
exist
the nurse was just me and the doctor
going
but doctor i think you're doing shut up
voice inside my head
that's that's who the nurse was
but i like this better this makes me
seem less crazy i make my own weapons
and do treatment for you if you're hurt
ooh even though this is true that never
really happens in the story
i feel like you shouldn't mess with her
like no
joke like no joke calm as much as i can
but don't you dare push my button
eyewitness man never yeah i forgot
oh tiny boxing
oh this helpless little gal in the
grassy prairie
everyone oh no
that's so cute oh no
i know what the next plushie's gonna be
ah it's so cute
that's what the sound of love is
i'm just kidding oh no i i'd go for it
cut the crap
we have to get out of here hey nurse you
never gave me an answer the last time we
met
uh-huh i didn't i don't really remember
that part
would you do me i don't think i that
that's really creepy
oh man oh that's cool damn it my best
effort
it's all to waste i bought this fedora
for nothing
to me
oh there's so many references i love it
oh it's so cool what is that is that a
giant ass on the ground
oh oh no it's a mannequin i thought it
was a giant buttocks
let's see if i can make that face
that's pretty good you don't look so
good
no i do not it's very true what
why because they're [ __ ] creepy i
just hate them
i just hate them they don't belong
whatever i'm not
real oh well that's not good
oh this is so cool yeah you can tell
that
he's been working on it for a long time
because some of these references are
from 2014.
and i mean it's cool that it spans it
all i'm not saying that's any bad sort
of thing that it takes place
a long time ago but it's so cool i love
it all
why i don't like that oh no thank you
god
damn these mannequins send you all to
hell
oh my god why do they have to shoot
blood explosions
that seems unnecessary i mean i'm i'm
appreciative of it
no get out of my way [ __ ] me okay
you can't beat my spam you can't beat my
epic spam
oh god
ah i can't keep up yes i did it all
i didn't even stop running the whole way
nurse oh there you are oh no
it's not nurse is it oh
okay bye thanks i don't know man
mark are you guys okay yeah
i didn't think we were gonna make it
yeah
those mannequins were scary you think i
have an infinite amount of explosive
some mustaches shooting out of my
nipples oh man that would have been
better if i'd been able to say that
correctly
but thankfully we were too pro super
way too pro i found out your dark ego
was behind this
i should have known my dark ego who's
that you talking about
darkiplier pretty convenient
wayne oh bob hi guys oh that's right
bobbin his dexter outfit oh i love it
what are you guys doing here did you get
sucked in this comic book too
yes yes that's wade's voice
yes no way this isn't about you by the
way
bob and wayne this is my nurse my nurse
i own her oh my god your melons are huge
jesus oh man you guys that's that's
inappropriate
they are perfectly natural thank you
very much oh yeah
wait think before you say stuff it was
just
a simple question it was a simple sexual
harassment that's what it was
right yeah whatever uh-huh yeah
oh demons
what kind of demons told you i faced
demons ah
okay die oh purifier
i'm gonna purify him i'm gonna purify
him
now that sounds more like wave getting
out of your way
i love it i love this because i remember
all of this that's from markiplier's
magic touch
now go oh hello oh hi
hello i got this i
got it yeah i got it am i gonna be
riding
yeah hell yeah oh
you think you can mess with the likes of
booth
oh my god yeah i don't think they stand
a chance i'm pretty sure i've won
already
we're just riding into the sunset here
this is not really a threat anymore it's
just
us no well that's
one down this here is easy yeah i
uh i'm way too pro for this my mustache
flinging skills is incredible
i love poof i love poof so much
it's the most innocuous thing that's
ever come out of a video
and yet it's so pervasive like forever
it'll poof will never die oh
now you're starting to get a little bit
of a challenge up i mean still not much
of a challenge but some sort of a
challenge
okay now my finger's starting to get
tired i shouldn't have wasted all my
poof skills way early on
ah oh maximum poofage
i think we might have done it did we do
it did we done it
are we done yeah
did it done it dunsed it done errone
din dunno completo my god
oh my god
wow
yeah come on fits to cuff me bro
don't take that as fists me bro oh god
mark i hope you know how to fight i
don't
does tiny box tina believe in me because
maybe it's gonna go okay
let's do this let's do this come
on i'm ready i don't know what i'm doing
i hope i'm still shooting boston's
[ __ ] well that was easy
ah my master plan why does everything
[Music]
poof
maybe maybe a little bit oh no
oh no
[Music]
are you crazy no
oh boy oh no
wait do i go do i go down do i go here
no
no apparently i don't that's oh god
apparently i don't do that because that
would be stupid
whoa what is this what am i doing am i
about to rock my socks off
whoa i don't think i can make that jump
nope oh i know what i need to do i got
it i got it i gotta bang this giant rock
testicle here
oh well ow i'm pretty sure he didn't see
that coming
[Music]
oh
i am lucifer with a
mustache chest hair is that what i'm
seeing
[Music]
yeah i'll try anyway i'll give it my
best oh
boy oh no is that his ankle or his ball
sack
oh no it says arm it's okay wow look at
those
abs abs for days abs for years abs for
millennia
oh gosh i don't know where i'm going but
i hope
hope i hope i know what i'm doing and
good thing everybody's helping me in the
distance
locked up in those cages huh all right
here we go
well i guess i'm bravely running away
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god yes
oh hell yes a floosh
yeah kill him kill him dead stab him in
his dick
yeah right up the butt stab his butt
oh [ __ ] you have been
purified you've been purified
oh did i die are my friends dead
oh oh no i didn't know you guys were all
at risk here
uh oh oh no
tina don't cry hi
i feel so guilty i never gave him what
he wanted
what's that a kiss oh
that's so sweet i'm proud of you
dad yes
it's me come closer
i i thought you were
i know son but my time here is limited
mark i'm proud that you saved your
friends and fans
i did but how do i get home don't worry
an exit will appear right before you
know it
[Music]
i love you so much
what were you doing so close to my face
i
i was so close to giving you cpr oh okay
i'm not dead yay
everyone cheer oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh whoops i i interrupted tiny box tim
celebrating there
oh apparently i'm ascending goodbye
everybody goodbye
i was never alive to begin with oh wait
no here we go
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
know we've been through good dude bad
times since we've met i want you to know
that you're a very positive and caring
man
you stand for what you believe in by the
time you're reading this
i've already moved on to a new life back
in the real
my hat to world me it will always
cherish the times that you had with us
and as always i will see you in the next
video
oh that's really
that was good i liked that
i liked that a lot that was good
oh man i'm so glad that he finished it
that was so good
i like that congratulations mark you
overcame your second adventure through
comic books seriously
well things seem to get weirder every
day anyway you overcame many obstacles
in yourself of three forms
but does this mean it's over you may be
safe
as of now but the final chapter of your
adventures await you
therefore to be continued oh
yes please oh my god
ah jeez oh man i'm
i'm being such a doof but that's so good
i love
that a lot that is so cool like it just
it
means a lot that these things are made
yeah john jay
howell jeffkyler14 who's an amazing
artist and just like
dedicated to this because i can tell
that you know this was started a long
time ago but i'm so glad that he finally
finished it because
it just means a lot that this was here
and it means a lot that you know these
things like exist
and you know i can see like the voice of
the community come through things like
this and i can see
i can see how you guys picture what i do
through things like this
and you know that they're really you
know that makes me really happy to know
that it's it's um it's it it comes
through like this
and and mst 3k man or
musket man i think it is just [ __ ]
awesome i remember all the heart that
you know they did and you know i i and i
remember like
i remember you know i remember all the
because over five years you see a lot of
things and you meet a lot of people that
you know
i do remember i remember you know i
remember
or i remember uh yeah i want to see a
message from the creator the game hell
yeah i do
thank you for playing my game i one day
hope to follow my dreams as a cartoonist
game designer and let's player
mark you inspired me to be a better
person and i wouldn't be anywhere right
now if it weren't for you and your fans
even if the person reading this isn't
mark i really appreciate your support
if you're willing to check out my
content feel free to subscribe to my
youtube channel jeffkyler14 and my game
channel jeffreykyler14 games
with lots of love i'll see you in the
next video bye bye
john j howell and that's really cool
because of like
it it's what it represents in a lot of
what what happened
in in my life and and over time
how my videos have affected people and
that's what's really cool about it
that's what i love about it and that's
what i love about these
these games and what they they show me
like they showcase the things that i've
done and
the way that it's touched people like
that's
it's super important to me so
i just wanted to say thank you to uh
jeff kyler14
please go subscribe to his youtube
channels please follow him on twitter
send him all the love in the world for
this stuff because these creative things
that are
made for me like hours and hours and
hours of work dedicated for me
like i i feel bad because i don't see
like i don't see all of them and i want
to
and i want to know them all and like
it's really important that it's all
there
so just thank you everybody so much for
being here and thank you everybody so
much for
like showing me and reminding me of
of like the things that i've done and
the person that i've become because
i i i never want to lose sight of that
and it's something that i've
like reinvigorated myself in in the past
few months and i'm just like
i'm very happy to be back to like where
i was
and i'm just really happy to be doing
this again so i'll wrap this up before i
get too
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you everybody who's ever
made me
art or made me a game i want to know
about it there
there's a dvr in our group that's been
around since since i've been on youtube
i'll put a link to all this in the
description if you have art i want to
see it if you have
a game that you've made i want to see it
you know i may not make a video about
everything but
you know i i just want to see it you
know so thank you everybody so much for
watching
thank you for everything that you've
made over the years and thank you for
like sticking with me for so long like
there's such a history on this channel
and i'm so proud
of like everything that's been done
because it means so much to me
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
bye